[Music]
cortney's has no here at the
Chappaquiddick premier where we talked
to kate mara about her house of cards
co-star Robin Wright taking over for
Kevin Spacey after his exit Tempe kept
in touch or what do you think about that
I love Robin she has always been one of
my favorite actresses of all time so I
think she's been sort of gearing up to
take over for a long time her character
and also Robin in real life is just such
an incredible force so I'm excited to
see it oh my god that body holds a lot
of Secrets those can be the difference
between guilt and innocence obviously
this is such an important film
it's an untold story of Mary Jo what
made you want to take on this role now
in the wake of everything that's been
happening in our country I think that
it's important to tell these kinds of
stories for a lot of the younger people
that I think don't know anything about
this time period and this specific
incident I think it's important to share
and and help educate everybody I mean I
didn't know that much about it either so
I think it's important for all of us to
know you know the history of where are
all of our politics and all that sort of
stuff comes from there's not a lot of
senators that are charged with
manslaughter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]